The Mother of Dragons got the mother of all
surprises on the last-ever episode of Game
of Thrones, and the actress who plays her
has got something to say about the show's
final, heartbreaking twist.
"Best season ever!"
Okay, no - not that.
Anyway, spoilers from here on out.
"I'll tell you everything."
In an interview with Entertainment Weekly,
Daenerys Targaryen star Emilia Clarke broke
her silence on the finale, admitting to the
public that she was in a state of total disbelief
after reading the scripts for season 8.
Clarke had just finished shooting Solo: A
Star Wars Story in October of 2017 when she
learned that the character she had played
for almost a decade would die at the hands
of her lover during the show's final episode.
She touched down at Heathrow Airport in London
and "completely freaked out" when she received
the scripts electronically - nearly leaving
her suitcases at Heathrow's baggage claim
because she was so eager to get home and find
out what would happen during the show's final
episode.
At that point, Clarke had yet to face the
facts of Daenerys' downfall.
When she did, however, she was beside herself.
She told Entertainment Weekly:
"I got myself situated.
I got my cup of tea.
I had to physically prepare the space and
then begin reading them."
Excitement turned to anguish as Clarke learned
of the events that led to Dany's devastating
death: her desperate fight against the undead,
the deaths of her closest friends and allies,
the loss of her second dragon and, eventually,
the destruction of King's Landing at her hand.
Having lost nearly everything, Dany finally
reaches the Iron Throne - only to lose it
all in a moment.
It took hours for Clarke to settle back into
herself after the revelation.
She explained:
"I cried.
And I went for a walk.
I walked out of the house and took my keys
and phone and walked back with blisters on
my feet.
I didn't come back for five hours.
I'm like, 'How am I going to do this?
Because it comes out of f---ing nowhere."
[when you say "worst TV ending ever" but then
remember Dexter's]
Learning that Daenerys would turn dark during
the final two episodes of Game of Thrones,
then be killed by a man she truly loved, did
a number on Clarke - whose emotions ran high
as she tried to process everything.
She said:
"I called my mom and [said] 'I read the scripts
and I don't want to tell you what happens
but can you just talk me off this ledge?
It really messed me up."
Despite being shocked out of her mind about
the events of the show's finale, Clarke noted
that the ending Dany got was the one that
made the most sense for her character.
She explained:
"After 10 years of working on this show, it's
logical.
Where else can she go?
I tried to think what the ending will be.
It's not like she's suddenly going to go,
'Okay, I'm gonna put a kettle on and put cookies
in the oven and we'll just sit down and have
a lovely time and pop a few kids out.'
That was never going to happen.
She's a Targaryen."
Clarke added that she felt Dany's conclusion
served as a full-circle moment for the naive
young woman viewers met on the first season
of Game of Thrones.
She said:
"It's a very beautiful and touching ending.
Hopefully, what you'll see in that last moment
as she's dying is: There's the vulnerability
- there's the little girl you met in season
1.
See?
She's right there.
And now, she's not there anymore."
Game of Thrones' final season will likely
go down in history as incredibly divisive,
and hugely disappointing to some.
But no matter whether you loved how Game of
Thrones ended or not, there's no denying that
the end of the show's journey - as well as
Dany's - won't be forgotten anytime soon.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.